E aí
[Música]
Bom primeiramente eu gostaria de
agradecer está aqui falando com vocês
para o Sedex meu nome é Andressa carício
e nós vamos compartilhar e alguns
momentos juntos eu vou dividir com vocês
algumas experiências que transformaram a
minha vida e que Talvez possa ajudar a
transformar de vocês também
e existem palestras incríveis existem
palestras de pessoas que subiram o monte
do Everest eu acho até que quando a
gente chega lá em cima as pessoas
distribuem senha ficha dizendo assim
você agora pode palestrar existem
palestras e pessoas que ficaram famosas
outros conquistaram milhares de
seguidores no YouTube tem também
daqueles que saíram do zero por um
milhão que tem que ser Olimpíadas dos
gordinhos que ficarão magros
e eu sinto muito eu não fiz nada disso
eu peço desculpas porque vocês vão ficar
18 minutos Ouvindo uma pessoa que não
fez nada isso pois é é o que tem mas eu
acho que eu sou uma pessoa normal e a
gente vai ter um papo aqui de pessoa
normal para pessoa normal
bom e como toda pessoa normal teve um
momento o momento específico na minha
vida em que todas as dores todas as
dúvidas ansiedade tudo aquilo que me
aprisionava que me colocava no local que
eu não queria estar que transformou
completamente
e eu tomei conhecimento e três palavras
mágicas e são sobre essas três palavras
que eu vou conversar com vocês mas antes
de falar sobre essas Três Palavrinhas eu
queria falar sobre duas Chaves Chaves
essas que mudaram os meus resultados eu
comecei a ter resultados muitos muito
próspero na minha vida resultados muito
positivos e a primeira chave chama-se lá
emocional
e eu não sei se vocês já escutaram falar
sobre isso conceito mas o lar emocional
ele influencia as nossas decisões se nós
não tivermos atento para ele orar
emocional é como se fosse uma casa e que
você se sente seguro lá não existe um
certo mas estão errado bom ou ruim é o
local que você gosta de estar
bom e talvez você esteja me ouvindo
perguntando se como que eu descubro Qual
é o meu lar emocional e eu posso te
ajudar com isso agora procura perceber
durante o teu dia desde a hora que você
acorda até a hora que você fecha os
olhos Quais são as emoções que você mais
se conecta quando você acorda
E qual é geralmente a sua emoção é de
entusiasmo por aquele dia É como se você
tivesse abrindo um presente e dizendo
assim o autor louca por esse presente ou
você acorda desesperado porque tem muita
coisa para fazer já Olha o celular olha
o WhatsApp tem criança para levar na
escola para quem é pai e mãe e daí Será
que você lá na mesa do café da manhã
Coloca aquela mesa maravilhosa e tem
tempo para se alimentar de forma
tranquila ou às vezes você nem se
alimenta porque não dá tempo talvez você
esqueça até uma chave e eu esqueci a
chave torne teu dinda mais desafiador e
você corra mais ainda
a e na hora que você chega em casa Será
que você chega e tem um tempo para
descansar ler um livro Ou você já chega
desesperado porque o dia não deu conta
de tanta coisa que você tinha para fazer
aí você vai descobrir no celular
emocional por exemplo
tu viu no passado eu tinha um lá
emocional que era do estresse então o
convite para vir aqui fazer essa
palestra para vocês o teste no passado
algo que seria bom para mim como meu lar
emocionar o estresse eu talvez nem
fizesse a palestra eu estivesse muito
nervosa ou aquilo invés de trazer uma
alegria exerce com que o meu Deus que
que eu vou fazer e eu preciso
compartilhar com vocês agora um exemplo
de como Lar emocional nos influencia
quando eu era criança eu tinha um herói
e o meu herói era o meu pai o meu pai
era porte corajoso determinado seguro eu
olhava para o meu pai eu dizer assim eu
quero ser como meu pai quando eu crescer
já minha mãe eu dizia não quero ser com
minha mãe que minha mãe era Submisso ela
dizia a menta que meu pai falava e eu
disse assim
eu quero ser jamais como ela porque ela
é muito boazinha eu quero ser aquela que
toma decisão aquela que haja aquela que
tem atitude daí eu pensava comigo quando
eu tenho 14 anos eu disse assim meu Deus
minha mãe conheceu meu pai quando tinha
14 começou a namorar com ele quando
tinha 15 ele era 10 anos mais velho que
ela e aos 19 ela casou muito bem aos 14
anos eu conheci um rapaz aos 15 eu
comecei a namorar com ele ele era dez
anos Rogério que eu e uns 19 eu casei
Ah pois é incrível como nosso lar
emocional nos influencia o sistema se
nós não conseguirmos olhar para ele com
consciência e diante disso tudo eu
preciso te falar que os padrões os
modelos ele sim podem influenciar Nossas
escolhas mas se nós tivermos consciência
nós conseguimos fazer decisões muito
positivas da nossa vida esse no avião o
avião ele tem vários botões tem um botão
que vai subir o botão parecer que vai
para direita e esquerda se eu não tenho
consciência como aquele circuito
funciona eu não consigo conduzir
e assim também a nossa vida quando eu
descobri que eu tinha possibilidade de
construir um novo lar emocional mesmo
que eu tivesse aprendido quando pequena
um ar diferente porque o primeiro olhar
que nós nos identificamos é o olhar do
nossos pais a forma com que ele nos
olhava a forma com que ele fazia
processo de identificação para quem não
sabe como nos chamava se algum deles
diária é tímida ou é muito extrovertida
e tudo aquilo na inocência de querer nos
identificar acabava colocando cada um de
nós numa caixinha e quando a gente
acredita nisso nós fazemos de tudo para
confirmar aquilo que acreditamos
em diante de tudo isso eu percebi que eu
queria construir um novo lá emocional e
eu posso ajudar vocês a construir esse
lado também receba hoje qual lá que você
se identifica mais porque para gente
sair do ponto a para o ponto b primeiro
a gente só saber aonde estamos depois
que você perceber Aonde você está aí
você vai dizer para onde eu quero ir se
for por exemplo da gratidão você
pergunte Quais são as atitudes e se eu
tiver diariamente eu trarei Exatamente
isso para minha vida e daí você vai
precisar fazer com hábito com
consistência E então você vai perceber
mudanças construindo uma nova casa
construindo um novo lar para que as suas
decisões possam ter novos rumos
diferentes daqueles que você tinha
anteriormente eu tenho agora uma segunda
chave para te revelar e ela é totalmente
conectada com essa
e ela também influenciou os meus
resultados para que eu tivesse o
Resultado positivo são decisões boas
alinhadas na direção correta e eu
preciso falar para vocês de um artigo
científico publicado em 1998 pela
Science Direct pelo Daniel Rizzi e pela
Bárbara vende vem e eles fazem um
convite para cada um de nós
e como estamos tomando as nossas
decisões nesse estudo eles convidaram
centenas de pessoas e diante disso eles
apresentaram uso guloseimas e tinha
chocolates bolachas banana maçã tinha
medo em japonês e disseram Assim vocês
têm o poder de escolha de decidir qual
guloseimas vocês querem mas a gente só
vai entregar para você Daqui a uma
semana a maioria das pessoas escolherão
frontais slime pro Futuro as pessoas
escolherão as melhores decisões muito
bem Uma semana se passou os cientistas
voltaram e deram uma nova oportunidade
disseram assim agora vocês Se quiserem
podem mudar a sua escolha ao invés de
fruta vocês quiserem outra coisa pode
ser e eles decidiram
é exatamente pelas goluseimas que não
faziam bem para sua saúde
e isso nos mostra que uma sempre
acreditamos que podemos deixar as
melhores escolhas para o amanhã
e amanhã eu olho para o meu
relacionamento Amanhã eu começo aquele
projeto que eu tanto sonho na minha vida
amanhã eu olho para o meu corpo para
minha saúde para mim as Finanças só que
o amanhã se torna hoje daqui a pouco
enquanto eu me desconecto do presente
daquilo que verdadeiramente vai fazer
bem para minha vida eu não consigo ter
bons resultados eu começo a ficar
amarrada num ciclo vicioso um ciclo que
não lhe traz abundância não me traz
prosperidade não me traz evolução Então
você percebe que essas duas Chaves
alinhadas vão fazer com que cada um de
nós possa ter resultados positivos na
nossa vida o que o que nós buscamos é
poder está alinhado com aquilo que é
essência de cada um de nós
e quando eu percebo que aquele caminho
que eu estava indo eu não preciso
acreditar que é uma linha reta todos nós
acreditamos naquela linha passado
presente e futuro e esquecemos que a
visão a espiral ou seja mesmo que eu
esteja descendo eu não estou mais no
mesmo lugar a vida ela nos convida a
perceber que quando mesmo quando eu
também estou em uma situação que
acredito que não é boa aqui não pode
servir de aprendizado e tudo isso nos
mostra que fracasso e sucesso são
resultados eu tive um Resultado positivo
ou eu tive um resultado negativo e esse
resultado se foi negativo Civil de
experiência aprendizado para que eu
possa continuar evoluindo nessa estrada
da vida
é mas eu preciso te dizer agora que você
descobriu uma chave que é do lá
emocional a outra é como ter bons
resultados olhando por uma escolha certa
com a direção correta mas mesmo assim
agora eu preciso te revelar que a sua
vida vai continuar igual é isso porque
e nem uma palestra nenhum Pede nenhum
curso nenhum livro vai transformar a sua
vida porque a única coisa que pode
transformar sua vida é você mesmo
colocando essas atitudes em prática o
conhecimento é importante lógico essa
palestra é importante sim mas se eu não
pegar todos esses conhecimentos e
consegui colocar no meu dia a dia é
apenas 18 minutos legais e passamos
juntos
bom então eu preciso te dizer que
pensamento positivo
e não vai transformar é preciso fazer
com que esse pensamento vire uma atitude
positiva que vai gerar química certa
para o seu organismo ao citocina
incrível ainda o fina maravilhosa a
dopamina e diante de tudo isso o teu
pensamento vai se alinhar com aquilo que
você deseja diante das suas atitudes é a
consistência e daí eu descobri as três
palavras mágicas que mudaram a minha
vida
é todo santo dia
o a consistência a força a perseverança
a vontade de ir adiante mesmo quando se
cai ao chão a motivação é a chama e vai
exatamente alimentar-se através da
atitude quando você tem uma atitude
positiva você alimenta a chama da
motivação dentro de você certa dietas e
sejam esporádicas não valem mais do que
uma consistência todo santo dia quando
você começa a perceber que são as
atitudes e você vai colocando e dinâmica
quando você ver que a transformação ela
é um processo que nós não podemos viver
para o evento
nós não podemos viver por dia Trinta e
Um de dezembro apenas por dia do meu
aniversário dia do meu casamento dia da
minha formatura da minha promoção não é
preciso se apaixonar pelo processo é
necessário que nós nos apaixonamos pelo
todo santo dia abrir esse dia como a
Maravilha como um presente para você
criar as oportunidades que você quer
para sua vida porque sorte são as
oportunidades que você cria quando você
percebe de um erro que você não é o erro
quando você visualiza que aquilo que te
aconteceu no passado não pode te
aprisionar no passado nós temos e
podemos viver de memória ou imaginação
mas se você viver de qualquer uma delas
memória ou cê vai se conectar com
passado pode ir para DP
a imaginação conectar-se muito com
futuro ansiedade então momento que você
precisa viver o presente é esse momento
agora porque ele é um único momento que
existe e partir de um desse princípio
você percebe o seu lar emocional Você
visualiza o caminho que você está
trilhando que não é a chegada mas sim
toda a jornada vão ser as dinâmicas os
movimentos diários a partir da
observação trata-se de um processo de
você com você mesmo único inimigo que
existe nessa vida somos nós às vezes Nós
pensamos que são as outras pessoas mais
só existe uma pessoa e se coloca diante
daquilo que você sonha você mesmo
bom então eu preciso te dizer que a
partir do momento que eu descobri essas
três palavras mágicas a minha vida mudou
eu tornei-me uma autora best-seller ela
e tenho ajudado todo santo dia milhares
de vida e eu descobri e o segredo da
vida é viver da melhor forma e se pode
os recursos que se tem respeitando você
sabendo que somos seres humanos e
portanto somos vulneráveis e como somos
vulneráveis nós erramos mas os erros
jamais querem nos destruir eles querem
nos levantar para que possamos ir para
um novo estágio da nossa vida
E aí